um ike involves a great example of it
but
of of rising through a map but this one
doesn't have a large structure in the
middle of it so you're
you're going up this really big
elevation and it's all open
um and so there's a lot more interplay
between the two teams as they're trying
to push up
up the hill and i i love d on the the
spawn rooms
uh with the cars and everything it's
just so
cool as uh yeah you just kind of see
both of these teams uh
you know come out of the spawn just a
lot of detail i love leaning into the f1
uh when when you have like the kind of
car going around the track
uh even the checkpoints is being you
know kind of like your uh
uh your kind of checkpoint how they
would be in like a race
yeah you see this so this first point is
uh really interesting i i think for a
lot of people
is where we'll see zarya on defense it's
like a
a solo tank like you can you can play so
many different ways right uh
i've i've seen people play like really
close up by like some of these
staircases a little bit further back you
can play the snipers up on the bridge
you can play
like soul drop on the bridge i think uh
just adds so much more dynamics to play
another we're having fun with playload
here it's a
ai driven f1 car or
race
it you know you know creating the the
escort
maps how does that different from you
know some of the other things you guys
are working on
you know like push uh you know like uh
you know hybrids controls like
uh is there a different type of
philosophy when going into start like a
map uh you know for escort or some of
those other modes
yeah there's a lot of a lot of
differences between these types of modes
and
when you when you do map design on
overwatch like one of the things you
always have to think about is where the
spawn rooms are going to be and how
you're going to get out of the spawn
rooms
and obviously it's it's different coming
out of a spawn room is different on a
payload map than any of our other map
types
because you immediately start
interacting with the objective
the one of the toughest things about
developing payload maps for overwatch's
the entire route needs to be like a
certain minimum
just to be able to get the payload to
fit through and usually you want to have
enough space
on the sides of it so that you can move
around there we do have
a few tight sections in our maps but
they're very short like right after you
get the payload in king's row it gets
very tight but that's
that's for a short period of time and so
when you do start making these wider
areas
it becomes very difficult to control
sight lines and it gets
it gets easy to make very long sight
lines through the map where
it no longer really feels like an
overwatch map
anymore because we really try to control
those things i mean it's i think it's
why you see that a lot of the payload
maps
they they do weave back and forth a lot
and so much of that is about controlling
sight lines and then also presenting
like difficult areas for
for a team to push through oh this is
the hilly section yeah so i was gonna
say that's the that's the area
of verticality where like uh there's a
sniper perch up here it's kind of like
that uh you know
right hand side if we're looking at it
but yeah just uh this poses so many
different obstacles
for teams but i also think it's it's
kind of
presents multiple ways to play where you
see right now
both teams playing the zarya but like
you could play really fast and kind of
dive up onto the high ground like you
can play really slow
kind of work your way around so
this team is just actually kind of just
rolling on through
zarya seems to be the tank choice of the
day
yeah and so that change is pretty new
you can see from a visual standpoint
when making a payload map
they're pretty large maps for an
overwatch space so we want the visuals
to kind of change as players
complete objectives the world looks
different to them you know
there was it was flat before and then
you reached the first objective and now
you're on the hill
and they'll move into the hotel for the
final objective so there's this visual
progression
to kind of your completing objectives
and you feel like you're making progress
through the map because the world around
you is somewhat changing
as it goes along kind of like uh like
dorado almost like right
think of uh you know a map from the live
game where you
kind of start through that choke area
goes towards that high ground
and then you have that like interior and
the interior
for this map is one of the cooler things
that
i've seen uh in overwatch and uh
hopefully we'll get to see it but
just the the tearing of it uh how how
did that come about with uh
when we go inside we'll obviously have a
better view of it but
it's really kind of like this
multi-tiered vertical
kind of like casino it's so interesting
yes it's a super cool space and really
fun to fight through i think
you know over time overwatch map design
is has changed a little bit just the way
that the the game has changed a little
bit
um the the presence or the importance of
high ground
really can't be understated in this game
and so we're trying to give
more of that to teams um and trying to
create
kind of like conflict points in some of
these maps and who's going to control
that hydra
yeah no i i think obviously it's a
shooter
right there high ground is always kind
of the
the go-to uh where
overwatch has always had the ability for
you know multiple players to take high
ground whether it's like a hanzo like we
just saw there like with the wall climb
or widow but yeah with like a
multi-tiered level like this
it allows everybody to kind of have a
some axis of high ground
which brings into play i know anna
really kind of effective here at the
high ground with the
grenades as uh we see the payload kind
of go over the line and
the car will go inside of the casino uh
i've seen a few cars inside of casinos
usually they're usually not moving
though
you know depending on how the day went
maybe they're moving but that's just
from my point of view
uh that's it this is the model portion
of
this is the hotel portion of the casino
yeah the luxury
yeah you can see the high ground in the
back over there it's actually really
difficult for us to put a lot of it into
our game
one of the things we do in overwatch is
um our stairs are very shallow
and we don't typically have any steep
ramps in the entire game
and i think the game plays better that
way it feels smoother like that
but it makes it so hard it just
kills the level designers on the project
trying to get people up to high ground
because it takes a lot of space in order
to do it
oh yeah that's actually a really
interesting point that i guess i
i've never really kind of taken a a kind
of a notice of yeah when you
like yeah the stairs aren't very like
these like long like windy climbs like
there's kind of turns to get to that
elevation
uh is that just to keep everything
smooth and just kind of
move and predictable yep so that's part
of it so keep it smooth keep movement
predictable
um it's it's also like it can be um
really like kind of um difficult
to overcome a really steep staircase
it's almost like a wall in front of you
and you don't know what's going to be at
the top of it
and so we always like for players to be
able to run through our maps and to be
able to look at a space and kind of
develop a mental 3d image of where
everything's going
of of what the space is actually going
to be like
outside of your view and it's easier to
do that with
shallower stairs it's also easier to
push up a shallower staircase in a
higher staircase and like lastly
just the way that a lot of games
character physics work
um it's also smoother to move on
steve staircases or on on shallow
staircases
it's gonna say the only the only really
i guess steve staircase i can think of
is uh you know the one on like horizon
lunar colony
uh you know on the first point where
you're kind of going up towards the
balcony
and yeah that that does kind of prove
like the some of the things that you're
talking about where
i know we've all been there where
junkrat is sitting on top of the stairs
with horizon you can't see where he's
shooting you from and you're just kind
of getting
pelted on the way up uh it's not the
best of feelings you know
yeah uh yeah i don't i don't really know
what to say about that besides
um we are moving away from 2cp
[Laughter]
keep the keep the combat moving i love i
love this area like you see where that
soldier is sitting
up top like uh one of the cool things
about
uh this map that i definitely saw when
watching it was that like
the attackers can actually like access
that area like you can go around uh
wherever you see connected up there
yeah curly mustache uh rotating around
uh and it's connected uh
that's something we haven't really seen
in a lot of overwatch maps yeah we tried
it we're very intentional with the way
we do flanking routes and we
we try to make it so that at least one
team like the team can be aware
of people that are coming on a flank
um and we usually don't try to let you
get
all the way around behind the defense
without having some way of knowing that
it's coming or having the offense
burning something like that and we think
this one's fair
we've gone back and forth on this a lot
there there's been 30 different
variations of this route
but hopefully this one's fair depending
on how
your game goes it's fair or not
who else is in the test um i actually
have some questions from uh
twitter that uh you know some people
have been uh pulling and just kind of
uh just really i think things that
people are interested in uh
for you guys what changed to uh you know
character
buff or nerf you guys most looking
forward to that you guys have uh played
around implemented with thus far
wow i mean that's a that's um it's a
great
question you know to ask yesterday but i
think
now that we've gone over um gone over a
lot of what we've been working on
there's
so many changes to characters all across
the board um
and it including all the big changes to
to the tank roll
the hero passives that we're introducing
with with all the other roles in
in the game so um as well as like the
the some of the
the work that we've been doing um uh
with uh like cc abilities in the game so
it's really hard
to pick one of those uh my personal one
is actually the one that we saw from
blizzcon wine
was the reinhardt stuff as somebody
who's always wanted to play reinhardt
he's pretty tragic at
it uh being able to be a little bit more
this is like selfish uh being able to be
a little bit more brawly
and more offensive uh is the type of
reinhardt play
i want uh on you know when i just charge
in
without talking any of my teammates
currently
now you can do that i'm sure i'm sure
that won't work in overwatch too either
but i can at least put it in my mind
that it could be a possibility
yeah that's always the promise of
reinhardt
um in any version of overwatch that
you're playing is that moment
where you get to drop the shield and go
in and just start laying waste
to people feels so good yes uh
you know you play reinhardt and you come
out and you feed a few times
like maybe maybe this isn't for me and
then you just land that one
shatter that that perfect shatter and
then you're just like yep
it's it's such a it's such a good uh
ability uh here's another one uh
from uh twitter uh that uh how do you
guys uh look at maintaining
the the balance between pvp and pve
i assume they're kept like completely
separate like different environments
like
but how do you guys how do you guys look
at that yeah that's
a really interesting question because uh
we talked a lot about that earlier we
started developing you know much larger
pve games
you know look at a hair like winston
winston is
super fun in pvp but a lot of his
enjoyment comes from
sort of how much you're willing to
commit and there's always like this risk
game you're playing and
you're taking space but are you you know
you don't want to be too far ahead of
your team or your healers and
how you're committing and everything but
it's hard to translate that to pe
environment for example
so that in our early play tested pve was
sort of like
he feels like he needs more and then we
started getting into like okay well we
really need to talk about if we're gonna
keep you separate or are we just making
changes to the face hero
um so a lot of the like for instance
that the current winston
alternate fire he has where he could
shoot that blast actually came from pve
first we were just like
oh this is a lot more fun and like oh i
wonder if this could apply
to the base kit plus we're doing all the
other chains of pvp and so we started
playing with it in pvp so
in those cases like if it feels like it
works and we like enjoy playing it yeah
we'll totally take it but i think
our general philosophy is try to keep
them separate um just so we can
make sure that they shine really great
on both the
both the individual game or all the
gameplays really yeah
i have to mention one thing really quick
because it's kind of fun
i did um early on i just had to make
this this uh
prototype but i did a prototype of like
a pvp ve mode i called it which is like
a
hybrid mode because i think like i i get
the
expectation that people will probably
ask about that pretty quick if we want
to do that and so i was like let's just
try it try him out of it
and it was a little dirty because it was
like there wasn't a lot of balancing
done it was just like oh let's just
throw all the crazy pv stuff in here and
see how they work against players and
it was pretty tragic but uh it was
pretty interesting and like
there's maybe a version of that yeah
exactly this may be a version that we
could do with at some point in the
future we don't have like direct plans
for that right now because it was
one thing came out of it like this is
fun but like man this would be a lot of
work trying to
balance this anywhere close to what it
would have to be
yeah we do a lot of experimentation like
that
um which i think is one of the funnest
parts about working on this game
and i know like oh as as they were
playing rome you know there was a
question of like hey are we
working on like do you work on other
game modes and it is something that we
do a lot actually
the push map or the push game mode came
out of a whole different game mode
that that we were working on um as we
were kind of trying to solve how you
would put
um a capture the flag into like a main
version of overwatch and we weren't
really able to do
it but push kind of came out of that um
and we are
we are working on one other one that i'm
really really excited
about um and hopefully it's something
that we'll be able to talk to
talk to our players in the community
about later
i love that yeah more ways to play is
yes he's totally fine with me and i'm
sure the rest of the community
uh well it's uh something that i've
actually kind of like
found throughout the day and you know
it's one of the things that's like a
little bit of new work to the live games
like the experimental card and then some
of the things you're able to do there
and try out things that look like
they've kind of made their way in
uh i feel like that has been a huge tool
for you guys
uh for really just kind of testing out
the april fools stuff
uh you know jeff i don't know if i can
convince you but give me the flying
sigma i don't know how that works
but like give me flying sigma so i can
just battle pharah's and ignore my team
but uh
a lot of a lot of some of that stuff is
really interesting that you guys are
able to try with the experimental
yeah it's been so powerful i mean i feel
like
it's sort of a developer dream in a
sense to be like because you're always
just like
i don't know maybe this is kind of cool
can we just like show this to people and
get their impressions
yeah we can't really do in fact we've
talked about in the past about expanding
maybe even showing more stuff but um you
know
what if we showed like crazy early level
layouts that was just all like gray box
stuff like how early can we show before
it gets like really ridiculous when
we're just like
here's a you know a stick man like is
that just like
not even worth getting feedback on or
what but like um
so it's it's it's been powerful and
we're still looking at ways to sort of
use it and
you know it's just another great
feedback tool from the community
what's so funny we were talking the
other day and it's like the april fool's
patch was ridiculous but then when
like you saw like some of the
communities like this is kind of cool
and you're just like wait no
like like like we get the sigma is cool
to fly for a day or two but like we
can't have that all the time right
so yeah so we see the
blue team kind of approach the the final
uh area and then
uh there was one question actually just
about uh the overwatch dev team
like uh how has it been you know uh
working from home
how large has the team gotten over the
last few years i feel like it's
it's really grown a lot um the
it's that the work from home is a bit of
a mixed bag you know
um and when we first when we first
started we were really worried about
how productive the team would be because
it's never something
it's something we haven't really done
before um and
we the team is amazing and they actually
like really
rallied and i feel like we are um just
as productive as we were before and in
some ways
we we are more productive about certain
things you know
um it's it's definitely there's parts of
it that are harder
you know like we don't all have
home offices you know like i'm just i
just work in my bedroom
you know i just have to make sure i make
my bed every day before i i go on calls
um and then the team it's um it's really
grown
we we we um kind of like when we shipped
overwatch one when it launched we're
around 60 to 70 people
and the team has continued to grow um
from there and i don't think we're at
quite 200 yet but we just keep growing
because
this the game that we're making now
overwatch too it's a
much bigger game than the original ones
it's even a bigger game than like even
when i started to hear about overwatch
too it was like oh
like yeah like this is gonna i i want
another overwatch and then
like just kind of hearing everything
that goes involved with it with like the
pve
and i know now all these massive changes
to pvp like
the scope of the game is so big yeah
it's it's huge um but that's it's
really exciting working on something
that has that many
aspects to it and the thing that that i
like about it and hopefully what we're
showing here today is
that we're able to work on something
that's new you know and it has all these
exciting elements
while still focusing on what like
made the original game great like we're
we are
like hey love or hate um
5v5 we are committed to to
like keeping the pvp of overwatch
as competitive um as possible and we are
putting
so many resources into it yeah just
pushing the game forward it's like all
the heroes that you love from
overwatch one with the learnings from
overwatch one just
evolutionized right you know pushing
pushing the game forward you know coming
up with new kind of creative
ways to play so this this transcendence
may seal the deal
yes reaper reaper did his dance on the
cart and
he was gone that